honk over this the name is pure back I
thought you know by now we're gonna play
into the gloom it's a new horror game
it's a pixel one which means it's gonna
be even scarier because the less pixels
the more scarier I'm sure there's a
graphic of graphic shard of that [ __ ]
somewhere inside my butt okay so this
made by emmanuel ramus I'm not sure if
he's the one who made all those other
pixel games but I'm it looks similar so
maybe it's inspired either way
I'm excited to play it where am I I have
not seen anyone for a while well me
neither
we're just came oh the sky is red that's
a great sign of death and suffering it's
jammed I'm at a hospital right looks
like a hospital how great someone wanted
to high-five walls Oh God
oh yeah what are you doing here he was a
murderer how do you know that
let's poke his nips 1 2 3 what you don't
have 3 nips come on a hanging corpse or
did this every everyone will pay hi
firewall sorry our perpetrator likes to
high-five walls and he likes to murder
people that are murderers sighs they're
all gent I'm all jammed hello bingo he
is watching toilet what'd I tell you
about not watching me when I take I've
gotta find a pipe what will I do with a
pipe better yet how do I open the
inventory to use a pipe there we go
so now I have a kite in my hand maybe
somewhere at the beginning we can Josten
time I like how the tree is going
through the house hey I hate when that
happens in real life
oh hello we did it OHE my arms can't
reach I need something
well luckily I have this leg I got it
yes good job Russ oh god it looks like
the apocalypse of a palace trees going
through walls and [ __ ] alright so now we
have a key the real question is
maintenance where's the name let's try
everything there we go
it's taking revenge did I take a ladder
oh it went somewhere down Oh God yeah
okay yep we're dead NBN's means you're
dead hello I don't think anyone is there
hello pretty fire don't kill me
I mean kills a lot of times in my days
and I'm gonna find of it Oh God Oh God
[ __ ] that is [ __ ] up man don't look at
me like that Hitler don't look at me
like that 800 a pause oh I love pencils
alright Oh God so dramatic okay
okay
okay so they all need to be connected
[Music]
all right get it out for me let's go I
have to pee so bad so if I urinate on
the head get right now it's not my fault
digger
Do You Know Who I am i box speak
let's go down
all right where are we machinery this is
okay man come on
whoa I'll be [ __ ] what is going on here
the door is locked and broken and [ __ ]
helped well it's too [ __ ] late now
innit
it's daddy's [ __ ] huge pull this [ __ ]
high chair how you doing great day is it
a couch they have it all here
some kind of polisher what the [ __ ] a
methyl group no gun oh god what the [ __ ]
what was that what was that I took a
poly share that's all you can have it
back you can have it back there's a hole
in this pipe I'm not gonna put my hand
in there all right it's logged I need a
key of course there's [ __ ] things
everywhere
I'll just really oh [ __ ] off all right
Chris I figured it out not by cheating
by sheer mental capacity brain brain
capacity
I know if whoever made this game
realizes that you can't just [ __ ] put
some blood on the wall and think it's a
horror game you actually need it to be
scary
we need to [ __ ] up our solution that I
spent so much time on and I think that
the piece will be one of these [ __ ]
always but there is [ __ ] 25 of
them so how do I know which one I don't
that's the that's the theory of it I
[ __ ] don't
oh my god it would first try mother guts
whoops oh my god I'm so dizzy what's
going on too much too much I feel
[ __ ] dizzy this game is I can feel
dizzy look here we go finally I can't
fit the volume in the hole it looks too
rusty that's what she said let's put you
there
well how did my unrest valve how do I
combine these two forces you did not
teach me how to do this then [ __ ] it
unrest it then runs to five rusta five
ice
oh my god powder what if I roll my face
on the keyboard
I must have gotten AIDS now time to
cheat I mean to think Supreme Leader's
fault so hold Cee to combine he's having
fun [ __ ] knows that [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
there we go what a great mother [ __ ]
puzzle holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
pizza all right deep breath all right oh
my god there's another [ __ ] dead guy
in this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
hey boss
it's no deeper [ __ ] right in the
[ __ ] sorry Oh more dead guy oh my god
I'm so scared
I thank you by the gods who is doing
this but the comments miss doing this
what do we get to make the access card
what are we supposed to pin that I think
we just sent in home oh yeah I remember
I'm not a big fan of this ambience and
it makes my nipples really hard and I'm
not that it's not a joke if they are
selling a diamond right now it's a
consequence of many years of playing
Oregon's my nips will turn to diamonds
after I get scared it's just how it is
I'm okay with it do I like it
maybe ah Mei wonderful I have to select
it and that's Prince Q it's [ __ ]
stuck why the [ __ ] am i sucking supposed
to [ __ ] oh my god alright let's just
go back and see if that does anything
else I'm so done I'm so done
helluva the Sultan's jab Nepal every
hempen Thursday yard at our health shut
up you shut your [ __ ] mouth wall
what the [ __ ] do you [ __ ] want from
me this is the door isn't it alright
alright alright alright alright alright
this storm is this door its distort why
not that door why ah why not it's April
oh my god so job sorry sorry
sorry I'm sorry my god ah alright
wear this alright I think I know where
this [ __ ] goes it's here isn't it
no well where then where
[Music]
what you say oh that you only meant well
oh that Mieszko yeah all right let's go
up here
maybe something actually [ __ ] scared
will happen no yeah cozy ass [ __ ]
music
I am play Barbie is scarier than this
[Music]
Barbie let's go here jelly feet done but
it's the font or do you feed him at this
table that cannot prove that you are
envious yeah I'm not nervous
Robbie cute yeah soft us is yeah bluntly
what was that I was a pawn of that you
can do that anytime look what do you
want what do you want what kind of
rocket are more puzzles [ __ ] me
oh there's [ __ ] stairs of [ __ ] who'da
thunk it the many feet died of and
handbag time father Jack left earlier
soft tummy victim victim Java Pizza
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] on a stick man it was
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm or doors yeah more there's no more
power with Italy Mary yeah all right
yeah we did it we went on an elevator
thank you thank you thank you
Oh spooks fear no ear yeah your first
carry met a more years [ __ ] my week
biggest weakness years no excavates of
years is cars with the essence they're
all identical
they're all [ __ ] identical either a
guy named Earl angry Richie Rich owns
five identical cars which i think is
like is illegal or the guy remained
outside seven or the guy who made this
was just [ __ ] lazy I'm gonna go with
nine
I don't have tag said it fella so good
now it's so good yet I want I can put
mapping the same time I won't stop it
probably [ __ ] tip you can't just
chase me like out of nowhere not cool
saving progress what you gonna do a bad
day huh what you gonna do a bad if you
following me I hear something I don't
like it I'm gonna go all right
well I would give this game a little
baby's pulling there because I was fun I
got chased I get building tension is
[ __ ] but before this is annoying
alright more cut we're in the process
now telepresence better shut up shut
your shut your mouth with you shut shut
all right there a lot that's great
you're not locked are you I don't have
the wire broccoli in the head blood all
right here we are it's a rat or a
frisbee or a moose or oh it's a chainsaw
that's what it is right
Who am I a mustache well we failed in
execution I hate when that happens
all right well I clearly missed a party
why can't I do duo
I don't know maybe you're not good at
dancing
everyone will pay ok chair that's great
there has to be something here I mean
otherwise this is a dead end I have yeah
oh it's another one of these [ __ ]
[Music]
alcohol I thank you cold yes all right
I did something I don't know what but I
did Matt but oh all right
don't fight me in real life cuz I'm nice
alright let's see did we if we see
something there we go
here's blood hi oh thank you
I found the plot the markiplier my
favorite kind of plot I would like to
fly that Mac player if you know what I'm
saying all right there we go
the various team Oh someone else it's
like let's cycle skies from x-men great
hello there
[Music]
and down we go more more progress
husband cept we're in the same way
oh my god those guys it just started ba
got it mapped in fact I have lateral
effect let's see maybe we'll find
something good like a life as any ones
like this somebody's got a pole and the
weather look nanny light no matter may
die they're looking at me like look at
me right now look bad oh that I knew
dude all right
many five-day save yourself or shut up
firing soon a fire here I think there's
fire up here alright spray away
the fire is down that's right at your
face oh oh no how can I get past oh no
I'm stuck forever my lack of Limbaugh's
skills I know they would hunt me one day
yeah dammit I'm so upset
hey box they've got more mazes that's
what I wanted right now
hey box
what Oh [ __ ] sake
you know at this aerial what is this
it's lost okay yeah great and we're free
hey hey
with daily press that was great that was
good and what was the point of that area
what was that schism [ __ ] victory
walk through another maze
oh my god I don't understand I don't I
really don't all right fool is walk out
then hey what are you gonna do there we
go
no more of the Year cars hey Vivek night
night night I did not come this [ __ ]
far what are you gonna [ __ ] tell me
now all right
I can run upstairs I am NOT a nice
tomato guys don't get these really
tell me listening gallery I've gotta go
some [ __ ] use my static powers let them
be them ha no all right now we got it we
got it we got it cool if I die now I
will ultimate rage on - my ass huh
my camera's really got a [ __ ] battery
because I've been playing this game for
three [ __ ] hours got it
don't look back I'm not even gonna do
that okay sorry I have a tix I can't
have like the it's a problem is stop
stop I've got please work please work
please work please work
thank you [ __ ] to God ah no guy oh
god oh god okay it's like I offered
something slaughterhouse yeah let's go
there oh my god this game are about
girls and now they're just regular girls
yeah dammit I got excited that for a
[ __ ] second man I guess my time key
got it
time key thank you
all right let's do not visit the
slaughterhouse oh my god
what have we got here matches [ __ ] am I
gonna do with matches why are you dead
all the time God get a life
all right now that we have matches I'm
sure we can figure out something great
to do with their life but like not play
this him outside all right there better
be something here there we go oh let's
throw down the matches in the witching
well how's that well you said it was too
dark so let's throw that on the matches
[ __ ] Alice teddy we should see don't
talk back to me well well well well
alright there's some more here there is
more oh hello there
hey don't let it know you were taking a
party okay okay don't potty on me
don't you dare fight it oh it went away
thank you small key I minded what it's
all oh I don't know but I appreciate
alright there's some more here there is
more oh hello there
hey don't let it know you were taking a
potty Oh God
okay don't pee on me don't you dare
potty oh my no way thank you
smokey I wonder what its fault I don't
know but I appreciate ere we go here's
the party I let's let's see here it's
locked
unless use this small key for it see
that [ __ ] all you just busy hanging it
around I do all the work
can I join this I mean I can join you oh
my got it it broke - I got a hook in a
rope that's cool
hey where do you guys go Oh a lightsaber
Thanks
what should I never probably this much
in my entire life it just fit more in
this game that I'm done in my entire
life Oh oui chef
that's a maza let's see if there's
anything here that we can do now we just
have this board against by a guy ah hey
ah now oh man my let's see if this TV
works I love every girl am I supposed to
know which channel islands and bars up
TV it's my favorite show maybe the time
is the key it's 3:25 Oh thought I was
smart in there for a second bid well
[ __ ] me I don't know okay maybe we can
use the hook on that they're watching
well in [ __ ] about it let's do that
alright now we have to combine
combination failed
yeah be more dramatic about it please
rope + bloody hook oh my god it worked
we have a rope and a hook oh my god
worked it's too dark while I have this
wooden manna come from oh okay so I got
them with a mannequin from the Rope
Donnie
that's what happened this wasn't very
clear the water was one deal when it
achieves that wooden mannequin the time
is the key the time is the cave
so why is it not it's 3:25 innit
it's three [ __ ] 25 that is not a
coincidence I've seen many coincidences
in my laughs but that is not one of them
3:25 help shut up mattress mr. Jane
time is the key Oh Oh the time is 625
come on what is wrong with me one two
three four five six seven eight nine 25
I am NOT 12 I know how to read the clock
yep 9:25 others I'm not stupid
I promise I know how to read the time I
should investigate that sound it
probably came from the church maybe the
gates are open now you naked son of a
batch at least I have the wooden
mannequin oh my god I feel so dumb right
now I look the gates are open what a
nice little coincidence all right then
I have percent by the mannequin of
justice hello friends family it's been a
good time
oh you have all come to make me that's
that's lovely
I always wanted to get married in a
church all right then I guess you saved
this one for me but I'm gonna put the
wooden mannequin here it's a young fella
suffice that that's me if I'm naked and
partying and I want now we sing that the
prayers of naked people naked people
they are fatter than you think
because we have been brainwashed by the
media and stuff
that's it you're welcome now that can't
be it Kenny I don't have any other oh I
need to let them i sorry sorry I forgot
I need to let myself on fire it's a tiny
detail that I keep forgetting
there you go sir where are you we could
think there you go you all right dad
damn don't you hick when you burn wicked
things thing when you just fall through
the floor it's like the worst I would
have got here alright when you fall
follow these items this reminds me of
freedom monsters nice Amiens
like I'm weary but still somehow nice
[ __ ] we just walk in circles sound what
we did family not very pleased my night
come on
[ __ ] me right I don't know buzz right
now I'm just thinking what the [ __ ] am i
doing oh maybe there's different paths
to take
so we have that one what about if we
follow this one see anything I know I'm
not the smartest finding one in the
[ __ ] all right that's clearly
surrounded by and dumped it if I go out
here creepy noises types sound like no
I'm not gonna go down there if I go down
here pretty big noises comes in I'm like
no I'm not gonna go down there there's
nothing really much to go by but hey
that's a candle here we can go by don't
get any weird noises I guess I should
follow them follow them my well and then
you're like oh look here's the end of it
nothing happens nothing happens
why am I just supposed to realize that I
finished the game and [ __ ] quit here
or oh my god well you know like I'm
gonna Yolo and say yo lowness I'm gonna
Yolo I don't want any items I don't have
anything to go by oh now I'm lost in the
darkness
good job me there's still there I don't
get it alright for this [ __ ] 50
goddamn time I'm still here
I still don't [ __ ] understand where
I'm supposed to go what
[Music]
are you melting my tanks right now what
I just walked come on you [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god I see it now the
[ __ ] candles our point as an hour
arrow
I am so dumb I keep getting so [ __ ]
angry because I'm dumb
that's not something very attractive
okay I get that but that [ __ ] is in
there like how am I supposed to [ __ ]
out all right
Savage
stop it Oh God come on it's so hard to
tell that it's an arrow seriously but if
you're in the right perspective then
yeah you can see that it is but you have
to be here to actually be able to tell I
guess I just have to [ __ ] button
which I don't like at all
oh god don't look like Loic back don't
look by five yards to let the back okay
that would be great
yes [ __ ] yes what we're backyard
no oh don't make me through the hit me
na what 65 right I can't I can't I can't
I can't I can't you can't expect me to
do this right now
all right just kind you have many
thought that you have a very fun Star
Trek that I have you back that you need
to help me guys
because I can't
I can't I [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me where is he I'll [ __ ] you I
don't know the [ __ ] code I'm so sorry
what are you gonna do about it
it's a Keith pipe room am I supposed to
[ __ ] some puzzles right now don't
[ __ ] do this to me three
Oh [ __ ] sake I've had one god proper
[ __ ] scare me man so for one thing
that is bad is to have to solve puzzles
while you're scared or being chased this
is no I very nice over that's seven so
one of them is seven I didn't see that
so three and seven three seven and two
[Music]
Fatiha
o my name it got it right
could've been any [ __ ] order you can
do this press oh my god it Thanks oh
[ __ ] oh my god [ __ ] fu me oh my god oh
my god I just want to go home
what more no that's not fair
you're being very unfair right now with
me
sir Kelly [ __ ] you wall [ __ ] you
help kill yourself [ __ ] you you can't
tell me what to do I've got ya
god I just want to go home and suck on
my Chinese seriously
all right I'm the one at yellow that's
great I'm finally free in your face oh
the tick-tock of the clock continued
it's much for that stabbing at a
relentless pace that showed the
inexorable power of time and the face of
people many events happened and Ethan's
family saving just greasepaint expensive
offal face until it became untenable
he then continued stuck in this world of
darkness suffering the torment of the
peril of life here while in our present
is funny they endured to the stimuli
that continually tried to reanimate him
keeping him alive to work and stuff only
the medical equipment carry entire life
however when his brain starts flowing
activity and with his family savings
defeated the doctor recommended this
night name ending his suffering
[Music]
heartbreaking crime full of distress
came from the deepest of his malice and
trash and transfer
cry so deep that it presented the
barriers of dimensions friction Ethan
miraculously in the last second before
disconnecting the machines that kept him
tied to this world
[Music]
Ethan reacted and with a weak impulse
from his frame followed by a fade and
slapping movement of his fingers his
tired mother noticed and told the doctor
and they could finally wake him up it's
mine came back other and us we couldn't
recognize her girl ever had at that many
blurry beautiful images came to his mind
however was their relation with the
present a familiar face is there no
friends or relatives not even a Messier
to face
[ __ ] and helping in the beginning very
singular ending very Sugoi
- awakening to a world full of lighting
I was even knew he could times to start
again and drink soda and [ __ ]
[Music]
thanks for playing
you're welcome Ethan you're welcome dad
was into the glam by Emmanuelle Ahimaaz
am I never promised what will it say a
minor drama Simon Ammann rymus okay so
let's let the be fair here when the game
started and it's a paid for title after
world so I am gonna critique it a [ __ ]
harsher than I usually don't bother
critiquing games at all because they're
free games and I feel like if they're
free then what's the point of this
ripping medal but it's only two bucks
arrived at this game but I just felt
like already started there was very
little stuffed sense in the game nothing
was happening you're learning just
walking around this huge environment not
really knowing why what you're doing or
why you're doing it or what is going on
so many dead ends and somebody weird
things and then you realize you're not
just walking in that maze you're
actually controlling the mace and you're
the one being stupid there's a lot of
that in that game so I think in a lot of
ways I was too harsh on this because
really it was my stupidity that was
because of it but in that maze part for
example the main Stossel in the
beginning it was completely
[Music]
it was kind of random to find that
cogwheel or whatever it was pretty much
a random puzzle and knowing that for the
rest of the game that all the puzzles
could be technically since the first one
was just a random solution then even
though they weren't then that just kind
of made me take a piss out of all the
rest of the puzzles even though they
were pretty good puzzles in this game
like i enjoyed solving them even though
i'm stupid as [ __ ] but hey at least they
managed to do it so yeah and i didäôt
the story in the end and it did have
some intense moments in the end and it
did have some good balance between
ambience and and chill like thinking
bands and tearing beans and chili and
danced it needs to have some contrast
our game and they had that I think a lot
of people seem to miss that but I hope
you boys enjoyed watching this with me
that's all for me thankfully really
liked and thank you for commenting I
appreciate it especially since this very
long video stay awesome res love you